il avait neuf cibles neuf personnes ont
été interpellées et placées en garde à
vue
c'est le bilan d'un vaste coup de filet
mené ce matin selon une source proche de
l'enquêté
tous sont déjà connus des services de
police pendant les perquisitions dans le
quartier des grésillés à
saint-apollinaire des stupéfiants et des
armes sont aussi retrouvés ce ne sont
que des mortiers qui sont utilisées
contre les forces de police quand elle
progresse dans le quartier de type
d'artiste à tout à fait ça blesse
gravement
il ya de nombreux résidus sur les toits
dans un communiqué le procureur de la
république de dijon précise les bilans
ont été découverts également trois
carabines des montées et des sacs
contenant entre deux et trois kilos de
cartouches dont des cartouches à blanc
et des cartouches de calibre 9 mm sur
place dès 6 heures du matin les forces
de l'ordre créé l'effet de surprise avec
un important dispositif leur aide
labeyrie une équipe cynophile en tout
près de 120 forces de police et de
gendarmerie
avec l'aide des pompiers il cherche
armée stupéfiants jusque sur les toits
de ces immeubles
les habitants eux ont pu apercevoir
l'opération depuis leurs fenêtres
monfils qui ce qui m'a réveillé tôt qui
m'a dit qu'ils avaient des chats qui
attendait les brides et pas que des
chiens qui faisait du bruit dans le
cerveau laisse clavette au rez de
chaussée on s'est levés ouvert les
volets que j'ai fixe qui avait coûté moi
je suis vraiment né ici quoi grésy c'est
la première fois que je vois ça c'est
pour moi ça c'est choquant traumatisant
même parce que jusqu'en a vécu là
dernièrement
puisse allah encore les enfants maudits
moment qu'est ce qui se passe encore
l'opération s'est terminée en début de
matinée mais dans cette affaire
le travail des enquêteurs ne fait que
commencer